[Musik]
herzlich willkommen mein heutiger gast
liebt die provokation die kabarettistin
und autorin lisa eckhard bricht tabus
und macht witze von denen viele finden
sie gehen eindeutig zu weit warum sie
das dennoch tut und was humor mit
wahrheit und mit dem tod zu tun hat
darüber sprechen wir heute herzlich
willkommen riesa eckert
ja sie haben mal auf der bühne zum
publikum gesagt falls jemand nachts der
vorstellung aufdringlich werden möchte
können ihnen gerne an die brüste fassen
aber dutzend dürfe man sich auf keinen
fall was haben sie gegen das duzen ich
sage dass bei jeder bei jedem auftritt
weil es mir äußerst wichtig ist das
problem mit dem duzen ist ja nicht nur
dass sich gesetzt werden möchte weil ich
als diese majestätische hoheit
gefälligst respektiert werden möchte
sondern weil ich immer finde dass beides
an wert verliert ich möchte mir auch das
duzen für wirklich intime beziehungen
vorbehalten und es wird einfach beides
besudelt wenn man sich nur auf eines
verengt und das finde ich trage ich also
gerade von einer generation also die die
mich bevorzugten das sind ja die die
sagen ja gefühl ist alles aber pronomen
sind nicht schall und rauch ja es ist
wahr selten so wichtig das richtige
pronomen einzusetzen aber leider nur was
das für mich wichtige geschlecht
betrifft und nicht das erzen und jetzt
und das haben wir schon verloren jetzt
ist es schon ein bisschen regierten ja
also da da wäre doch sprachliche
vielfalt schön also dass da gab es ja
eine eine einer riege an möglichkeiten
die man miteinander in kontakt tritt
aber das scheint nicht mehr wichtig also
würden diese jungen würden sie sagen das
ist eine generation die diagnose die sie
machen sozusagen die eu unter was ich 30
jährigen dass die sozusagen die oft ist
du und du gehen dieses echtheit
authentizität sie jerusalem ist warum
ist das so
dass ich glaube das hat vielfältige
gründe ich kann immer nur sagen warum es
mir schon wieder ist ja ich betreibe
nicht küchenpsychologie für deren kleine
pathologien aber ich kann ihnen ich
versuche ihnen zu vermitteln auch dem
jungen publikum warum es ein
ästhetischer verlust ist und warum es
auch eine frage des respekts und des
anstands
und das sind eben ungeschriebene gesetze
die ich weit höher schätzen als die die
man gerade festschreiben will wie man
einander höflich begegnen
der soziologe richard sennett hat man
von einer tyrannei der intimität
ich brauche es gibt ja wenn man heute im
öffentlichen verkehr unterwegs ist die
leute plan als ins handy und schminken
sich und soweit es schon hat sich schon
einiges verändert und sie meinen nicht
zum guten nein das war nicht nicht also
dass diese trennung zwischen
öffentlichkeit und privatsphäre
eingerissen wurde ich halte das für eine
katastrophe also jetzt gibt es noch zwei
sichtweisen die nähte hre wäre dass man
sagt es gibt jetzt nur mehr
öffentlichkeit alles ist öffentlich ich
finde aber es ist jetzt alles
privatsphäre es gibt keine
öffentlichkeit mehr jeder fühlt sich
natürlich nirgendwo daheim ja als als
anywhere und
beliebt sich dann auch soja als wäre
überall zu hause und es natürlich wenn
niemand mehr eine rolle spielt und immer
nur als er selbst auftritt sofort diesen
waren wesens kern von dem ich nicht viel
halte aber ich will ihn anders lassen
wenn er den gleich offenlegt gibt es
keine möglichkeit als jede sekunde
gekränkt zu sein weil man alles
persönlich nehmen muss das ist
interessant also das spielt danach zu
sagen ihre kritik an dieser wie sie
sagen empfindlichen generation
-generation snowflakes wir sind kleine
schneeflocken die dann zerfallen wenn
man sich nur das berührt darüber werden
wir noch reden aber sie betonen dass
ihnen diese diese figur auch diese
höflichkeit dieses formelle sehr wichtig
ist die trennung zwischen öffentlich und
privaten man sieht dass innenraum wenn
man sie erzählt wie sie hier sitzen aber
auch wenn man ihnen ihre bühnenauftritte
sid sie sind erst 30 jahre und darf ich
sagen sind eine der erfolgreichsten
das ist schon ein problem dass sie sagen
erst 30 jahre alt das wirklich der
generation auch vor dass jemand mit 30
noch irgendwie die nach in freiheit
eines kindes genießen mit 30 meine ich
aber für das was sie schon aus geleistet
haben sie haben ein buch geschrieben
zweite erscheint sie sind eine der
erfolgreichsten aber auch umstritten
sind kabarettistinnen im
deutschsprachigen raum sie füllen große
hallen sind stammgast in der ard-sendung
nur
im ersten bei dieter nuhr gewinnerin des
salzburger stiers und diese
bühnenfigur hat etwas sehr
elitäres arrogantes provokatives machen
also fast zur domina mäßiges möchte ich
sagen und damit wir so einen eindruck
bekommen wie sie auftreten auf der bühne
schauen wir ein ausschnitt aus der
sendung bei dominique de will und da
geht es am anfang auch uns duzen es ist
nicht ganz leicht als frauen dieser
szene es kommt immer wieder vor dass
mich alte weiße männer hinten im
backstage
dazu zwingen
sie zu dutts
und ich will das einfach nicht aber
manchmal gebe ich nach aus angst dass
sie sonst nicht mit mir schlafen
ich musste ja sogar meine eltern noch
siezen aber wo hört man heute noch ich
danke ihnen herr papa für jede einzelne
leviten kraft ihre schläge auf meinen
popo habe ich heute keine cellulite
selten aber früher war das ein guter
indikator wer ob jemand seine kinder hat
steht man an der bindehaut
aber heute ist alles so amorph und
distanzlos dieses dauernde diese
ständiger umarmen küsschen hier küsschen
da mich macht das ganz paranoid glaube
ich immer man verrät mich schon wieder
an die römer geben wir uns doch wieder
die hand aber die handschlagqualität
lässt bei vielen zu wünschen übrig
selbst männer schütteln sie oft so lose
dass ich mir ernsthaft sorgen machen wie
die zuhause onanieren
land habe bin ich weg
war so einem handschlag dann kann ich
mir schon genau vorstellen wie la black
der mich später wirkt
ja wir sehen sehr provokativ auch lasziv
möchte ich sagen
liegt ihnen diese rolle von natur hass
oder ist es gerade umgekehrt sind sie
privat ganz anders ich würde sagen ich
bin privat gar nicht also diese person
abseits der bühne die in meine koffer
trägt die halte ich wirklich für für sie
irrelevant und langweilig sie tritt auch
mit anderen nicht in kontakt weil das
trägt vielleicht so ihre langeweile bei
sie ist ein großer philanthrop also ich
sehe mich als solche und
um ihr diesen diese philanthropie zu
erhalten habe ich kaum kontakt zu
menschen also ich habe ja dass wir sie
lieben die menschen weil sie so wenig
sehen diese illusion ist ich möchte mir
das nicht zerstören ich möchte aber auch
die menschen nicht entzaubern und das
passiert automatisch wenn ich von der
bühne steige wie vom himmel herab ich
möchte kaum in kontakt treten weil sie
sind enttäuscht ich bin enttäuscht
lassen wir lassen wir diese magie sehr
romantische idee das leben in dieser
idealisierung auch und erzähle die
direkte begegnung dann oft enttäuschend
ist also den den eindruck habe ich
zumindest deswegen halte ich mich halte
ich nicht aber die person die die koffer
trägt die ist ja doch jemand also sie
sind vor knapp einem jahr mutter
geworden sie haben bei freunde
beziehungen sitzen zu hause manchmal
allein
sie sind ja nicht immer in einer rolle
drin nein aber es ist tatsächlich meine
beziehungen beschränken sich auf das
magische dreieck aus mutter management
und man also mein kind schwebt da
dazwischen aber ich muss sagen seit ich
mutter bin ist es noch schöner damit das
kind geholfen hat
also zu dieser zu dieser selbst and
wirklichen zu finden die ich immer nur
in der kunst gesucht habt also das
schönste am muttersein ist dass ich
jetzt weniger zeit für mich selbst habe
und das war eigentlich immer die selbst
der autor destruktive zeit weil ich mich
gefragt habe wie es mir geht ich habe
introspektion betrieben und nicht sie
schädlicher für die kunst nichts macht
das schlechter als immer das wühlen im
eigenen selbst und ich habe viele dieser
dinge dieser schädlichen dinge jetzt
endlich aufgeben können und das ist
herrlich und es macht mich einfach
ruhiger weil ich jetzt durch das kind
das werk entlaste mein werk weimar dafür
zuständig mir und sterblichkeit zu
garantieren und jetzt attackiere ich die
sterblichkeit von zwei fronten und
logisch und kulturen genau kennt und
bücher oder vielleicht schaffe ich es
auch noch religiös ich bin spirituell
nicht so begabt aber ich arbeite an
diesem dreier weg und insofern bin ich
wahnsinnig entspannt das darf man jungen
mütter nicht sagen weil das tier auf der
ein wenig neidisch aber es ist leider so
man spürt sondern diese geste von von
oben herab ach diese ungeheure distanz
die sie haben danach zum publikum das
sie oft auch daneben wie
nicht belästigen aber beleidigen
vielleicht so diese dieses von oben
herab das ist ja wenn man sozusagen in
die philosophie zurück geht in die humor
theorie was humor ist ist es bei platon
danach beim thomas ochs das gefühl der
plötzlichen überlegenheit deswegen
lassen da fährt jemand hin scheitert wir
wissen dass sie nicht wie es dann
gelaufen genau darum geht es und
deswegen bin ich immer sofort
wenn man mir den vorwurf macht ich trete
nicht nach oben weil ich blicke auf der
bühne empor und da ist nichts nichts
steht in diesem moment über mir außer
der kunst und dem humor humorist ist
hybris in reinform dar also darum geht
dass man wird immer fragen also vorüber
niemand wird je unter etwas lachen das
heißt worunter leidest du und das ist ja
gerade er das gebot der stunde nur humor
kann nicht leiden was nicht heißt dass
er die verzweiflung nicht kennt ja es
ist mir immer sehr wichtig weil ich
meine wir lachen ja nicht umsonst tränen
und ich finde der humor sublimiert das
weinen dass ich nicht für eine
kulturleistung heute wie alle kommen
rein und auf die welt und wie ich jetzt
gerade selbst bei meinem kind sehen
dürfte das lachen setzt erst später ein
das scheint mir wünschen eine
kulturleistung erst nach drei vier
monaten beginnt dieses wesen das immer
nur geweint hat zu lachen und ich hatte
den eindruck er lacht jetzt nicht weil
er alles so großartig ist sondern weil
es
irreparabel hoffnungslos ist er hat vier
monate geweint und festgestellt sie wird
mich nicht wieder in den ozean befördern
und er kann nicht gehen er kann nicht
sprechen und nicht wissen ob es jemals
können wird und klar wer da noch weinen
kann der hat den ernst der lage nicht
begriffen also die tragödie kommt zuerst
und dann die komödie also die
verzweiflung ist zuerst das leiden und
das lachen systeme sublimieren form von
beiden würden sie sagen ja ich kann mir
nicht auf die fahne schreiben das
konzept erfunden
also so halten es einige schon vor mir
so gehalten aber ja ich würde auf jeden
fall so verfechten was würden sie sagen
bei ihrem kind was war das erste
humoristische lachen
moment wo sie gesagt haben er hat humor
jetzt schon es war die überraschung und
ich fand es sehr interessant bei dem
kind zu sehen dass gewisse humoristische
kategorien angelegt sein müssen weil er
hat über dinge gelacht wo ich nicht
verstanden habe wie kann er jetzt ohne
satirische vorbildung das verstehen wenn
ich grimassen schneiden ich könnte ja
auch ein herzinfarkt haben und es wäre
wahnsinnig sadistisch von ihm da zu
lachen aber er versteht imitat was ist
humor und was ist ernst eine fähigkeit
die mine ein paar monate altes kind
beherrscht aber viele zeitgenossen nicht
mehr das sollte zudenken geben diese
überraschung ich sage interessant es
gibt ja dieses spiel dieses kuckuck
spiel wo man das gesicht verdeckt
gekommen das ist wie das erste lachen ja
das ist ja auch da drin steht ja auch
die angst die mutter die mamas wäre papa
ist weg orientierungslosen dann wieder
zurück also man sieht auch da wie humor
und furcht begehren und und angst dass
sich das alles vermischt und was für
eine erleichterung dass lachen immer ist
dass etwas furchtbares nicht eingetreten
ist oder man kurz damit gerechnet hat
und das hat nichts bösartiges an sich
weil das was heute gern passiert es dass
die menschen von denen mir scheint dass
ich humors konzept gar nicht mehr
schätzen nicht mehr verstehen dass sie
wo immer gelacht wird es für
schadenfreude halten und das ist
schadenfreude ist etwas völlig anderes
ich habe schadenfreude wo man ja über
etwas schlacht und nicht trotzdem was ja
die definition für manche von humor ist
wenn man trotzdem lacht man lacht über
etwas und ich finde die schadenfreude
ich sehr nah am mitleid wenn so mitleid
noch so ein funk neid kommt was ja heute
sehr populär ist nicht nicht nicht
futterneid sondern seinen hunger leid so
der mensch dass ressentiments wir ändern
wenn sich das noch zum zur schadenfreude
mich dann kommt mitleid raus und
deswegen bin ich da immer sehr sehr
vorsichtig bei diesen menschen weil da
gibt es auch wenig wenig zu diskutieren
ja wenn humorist kategorie wenn das
fehlt wenn das nicht wichtig ist weil
man meint fälschlich mit den zumutungen
des lebens anders umgehen zu können ich
kenne aber noch einen anderen guten weg
dann wird es für mich ein hilft ihnen
der humor wirklich wenn es ihnen
schlecht geht
schaffen sie da dieses die distanz zu
bayerns du dich selbst und über sich zu
lachen ja also ich würde sogar sagen es
geht mir nie schlecht dass humor ist
also es ist es funktioniert tatsächlich
ja was mich am meisten beschäftigt das
läuft auch gleichzeitig alle anderen
kleinen wehwehchen ist meine angst vor
dem tod des immens man sagen vielleicht
ein bisschen voreilig für jemanden in
meinem alter aber da da verblasst
jegliche kränkungen und kleine micro
aggression weil ich mir selbst in
unangenehmer momenten denke mein gott
hoffentlich habe ich noch viele von
diesen unangenehmen momenten weil
irgendwann ist es vorbei und dann kann
ich nicht mal mehr mich über mikro
aggression er chauffierte
darüber über diese mikro aggression
werden wir noch reden aber der der humor
das lachen nach als versuch mit dem
letzten großen scheitern umzugehen und
taboo mit dem tod ja also das hilft den
auf jeden fall ja also beziehungsweise
hilft ich glaube es gar keine strategie
die ich die ich bewusst an wände sondern
ab einem gewissen punkt der verzweiflung
kippt man ins lachen
vielleicht kennen sie das auch von
beerdigungen ich kann keiner beerdigung
beiwohnen weil ich immer ein
hysterisches lachen ausbrechen weil man
nicht lachen darf gerade weil man lachen
darf und auch weil es wirklich teilweise
ich war bei beerdigungen von menschen
die mir sehr lieb und teuer waren und da
bin ich an eine grenze gestoßen und wenn
da irgendwie der gefühlshaushalt versagt
nicht mehr weiß wie es kanalisieren
sollen dann lacht er also das ist dieses
dieses irre lachen was nichts damit zu
tun hat dass man etwas nicht ernst nimmt
dann gegen im gegenteil es gibt auch die
theorie des deutschen philosophen
helmuth plessner da sagt machen ist
genauso wie wein einen grenze reaktionen
bei dem wenig mehr weiter wissen wenn
jetzt die dinge zu nahe rücken dann
wollen wir wenn wir die welt nicht mehr
in ein einheitliches bild klein können
diese widersprüche aufeinander der
verstand seine grenzen kommt dann landen
wir so was würden sie sagen das ist auch
ihre
und das macht mir leute auch extrem
sympathisch ich weiß nicht ob man das
mitbekommen hat hier es gab ja in
deutschland einen kanzlerkandidaten
dessen größtes manko war ein fauxpas
also mal nach dieser
flutkatastrophe gelacht hat und vor ihm
stand der bundespräsident und hat eine
rede gehalten und ich dachte mir
eigentlich nur wir dann mit finsterer
miene stand der bundespräsident mein
gott angesichts dieser tragödie wie kann
der da so ernst bleiben und dass im
hintergrund wie der wie der gelacht hat
das fand ich das fand ich sehr
menschlich und
keinen humor und kein lachen findet man
wirklich nur einen fundamentalisten oder
im paradies weil da gibt es nix um
darüber hinweg zu lachen also gott es
gibt wenig bibelstellen wo überhaupt
gelacht wird und im paradies ist man
jetzt auch keinen großen humoristen adam
und eva aber warum hätten sie es auch
sein sollen vielleicht fehlt die
tragödie da sehen wir werden uns später
noch über auch dass die des humors reden
und die frage ob man wirklich über alles
lachen darf möchte ich noch ein bisschen
bei der biografie bleiben sie sind die
ersten sechs jahre ihres lebens haben
sie bei ihrer oma meine großmutter
gelebt weil ihre mutter glaube noch in
ausbildung war als lehrerin dieses buch
ist vor zwei jahren erschienen um einmal
das dreht sich um das leben ihrer ihrer
großmutter das sind ja nicht die
prägendsten jahre des lebens die ersten
drei vier fünf jahre wollen wir uns
nicht daran erinnern was hat sie ihnen
vorgelebt wie hat sie geprägt
notgedrungen langsamkeit also was jetzt
schon bei meinen großeltern nur ein
vielleicht motorische einschränkung war
habe ich mir sehr als
lebensart angewöhnt ich bin unfassbar
unfähig zur spontanität ja ich glaube
meine großmutter wer spontan gewesen
aber sie konnte nicht so schnell zum
telefon um jemanden anzurufen wir haben
mir fehlt dafür die die psychische
verfassung um schnell in kontakt zu
treten mit menschen also ich bin sehr
sehr geruhsam sehr kontemplativ dadurch
geworden und das ist natürlich etwas was
sie in keinster weise beabsichtigt haben
deswegen möchte ich sie an dieser stelle
nicht loben aber ich freue mich
insgeheim sehr darüber ist die sie nach
eine geisterfahrerin gegen den zeitgeist
weil heute ist aus schnell
beschleunigung multitasking zu weit und
sie sagen sie haben sich diese
langsamkeit er nicht verinnerlicht also
diese menschwerdung weil
multitasking das ist ja etwas also zwar
wird es jetzt als wert an aufgerufen
immer wieder aber multitasking ist etwas
zutiefst irisches also wenn man sich
nicht in eine sache vertiefen kann und
kurz auf etwas konzentrieren tiere
dürfen das nicht wenn sie schon
gefressen werden also das halte ich für
für alles das sind sehr unkultivierte
tugenden deswegen meine ich man muss
sich öfter senioren und alte menschen
anschauen die leben sehr sehr würdevoll
sogar wenn es in unseren augen nicht
mehr würde voll ist was wir euch solches
erachten ja wenn es biologisch etwas
ungustiös wird aber das ist etwas
weiteres was mich sehr
ja also was ich was ich christ finde ist
eben diese verachtung für das alter und
diese nicht haben das hat mich die zeit
auch gelehrt dieses kultivierte das
pflegen sie hat so ein bisschen wie
passt das zusammen mit dem lächerlichen
wir sind nach sehr lächerlich gewesen
also dieses oft so einige tun
ja aber es das ist doch gerade ein grund
dass der bodensatz so lächerlich ist mit
dieser ich weiß nicht was günther anders
der sagt diese und tische mit gift ist
natürlich auch ein sehr kultivierter
begriff um auszudrücken dass es eine
zumutung ist dass wir hier hin und her
philosophieren und danach auf die
toilette gehen ist also das ist
schrecklich aber das sind ja ich finde
das schrecklich aber gerade das ist hier
zu sitzen
aber gerade deswegen kann ich mich doch
nicht gehen lassen in den anderen
momenten ich muss doch umso mehr
übertünchen rhetorisch west je um das
nicht zu zeigen und zu verheimlichen und
das sollte uns ja in die höhen treiben
ja und dass das finde ich schön dadurch
dass diese dass dieser stuhlgang auch
gleich morgens geschieht dass man weiß
okay das ist passiert und jetzt habe ich
einen ganzen tag um das wieder
gutzumachen und mich möglichst als
übermensch zu gebärden auch wenn ich
weiß dass ich es nicht bin der prozess
der zivilisation
wir bleiben noch wissen bei der
biografie sie haben ihr gymnasium
abgeschlossen die matura mit 1,0 habe
ich gelesen also bestnote haben danach
germanistik und slawistik studiert in
paris wien und berlin und die
masterarbeit entschuldigung nicht in
viel entschuldigen sind und wo will ich
immer angedichtet ja als als
österreicherinnen und das sage ich auch
in der bewertung demokraten ich hätte
gerne in wien studiert macht aber nicht
weil der ausländer der deutschen anteil
so groß ist ich sage ausländer damit es
nicht so hart klingt als sind die
deutschen das problem entschuldigen sie
ich wollte nicht um
ihre masterarbeit haben sie geschrieben
zu einem interessanten thema sondern das
zweite thema und zwar hat zu der figur
des teufels in der literatur und was ihr
aufhört ist dass der teufel zum beispiel
bei goethes faust der mephisto sehr viel
humor hat warum ist das so warum hat der
teufels immer oft so viel humor
weil er glaube ich
ihn treibt schon ein will ein bisschen
die hoffnungslosigkeit
also er ist ja ein armer teufel auch
beim faust er kann im großen nicht
verrichten und stellst darum im kleinen
an und das war auch immer mein credo ja
solange ich nicht irgendwie mich doch in
der politik aufschwingen würde und die
macht an sich reißen kann ich es auch
nur im kleinen verrichten und schon mal
diese einsicht der eigenen ohnmacht
macht lustig also letztlich der
größenwahn eines faust der sehr sehr
ernst nimmt
verdammt in seiner extrem lustigen figur
das ist der der teufel dem wohnt der
sprachwitz in diese rhetorik und wenn
man wenn man sehr also ein streben ist
ja an sich nicht schlecht aber ein sehr
verrannt es streben da geht einem
irgendwann auf dem weg der humor
verloren ist der teufel ihren
menschenfreund und menschen vereint
ich würde ihn so einschätzen wie mich
also er sein menschenfreund der es aber
nicht zugeben will und also erstellt ja
dann auch obgleich er sagt das böse will
immer das gute an insofern ist er
wahrscheinlich eher der philanthrop als
die schönen seelen die stets das gute
wollen und wie wir wissen dass böse
schaffen das böse ist ein schönes
stichwort ihre programme drehen sich ja
wirklich um alle themen auch um den
krieg in der ukraine
und wir scheinen es damals einen
nächsten ausschnitten aus einem auftritt
in dresden da geht es um die deutschen
um das böse und den krieg aber auch um
diese empfindlichkeiten die sie schon
angesprochen habe sie die deutschen sie
sind nicht ganz glücklich damit oder das
jetzt ausgedient haben als die bösen sie
denken sich jetzt nur gut gut wenn wir
den krieg schon nicht beginnen dann
werden wir im bmg indem sie waffen
liefern
angesichts der qualität ihrer geschosse
wollen sie der ukraine liefern sie die
waffen besser den russen
man muss aber dazu sagen das war ja
lange ein garant für frieden die
bundeswehr kaputt zu sparen also damit
sie nicht wieder durch drehen das war
wie eine chemische kastration für
triebtäter
jetzt aber wo plötzlich ein anderer
durchdreht weiß deutschland nicht warst
du auf richtung abrüstung das einzige
was man trainiert hat ist enttäuscht
weckt entrüsten auf twitter nur david
gewinnt man keine kriege man kann nicht
jeden zweiten tag einen general
auswechseln weil er weder das
diskriminierende es gesagt hat über den
gegner
während der schlacht er hat den gegner
feind genannt und befohlen
zurückzuschießen
das ist hate speech dabei war ganz klar
ob gemacht am schlachtfeld keine micro
aggressionen
ja sie stich und da schießen dagegen
diese woge generation
und ist die these dass wir heute über
empfindlich geworden sind zu sensibel na
ja wir sind wir sind sensibler geworden
empfindlicher was ja auch was gutes an
sich haben die sache ist nicht per se
aber ich finde der grund werden wir
geworden sind ist ein guter nämlich dass
wir tatsächlich
weniger schmerzen leiden also wir haben
weniger makro aggressionen wie jetzt
etwa einen krieg das bedeutet aber wenn
man so eine ökonomie des schmerzes
glaubt dass sich der schmerz denkt man
gleich bleibt er fragmentiert und dann
hat man eben statt einem wuchtigen
schmerz wo man sich früher in einer in
einer schönen bar prügelei gütlich getan
hat jetzt eben am tag um auf diese
schmerz niveau zu kommen 100 mikro
aggressionen zusammensuchen muss um auch
schmerz zu fühlen der einen ja der einen
ja konkurriert in gewisser hinsicht also
keinen schmerz zu fühlen ich glaube dann
würde man zerfließen das kann nicht das
ziel sein neben allen schmerz
auszurotten
das ist eine anthropologische these über
den menschen dass er sozusagen das
schmerz niveau ungefähr gleich bleibt
egal wie gut die welt ist sage ich jetzt
es gibt auch von alexis de tocqueville
dieses paradox so sie gerechter ihr
gleich für die gesellschaft wird desto
eher fokussieren wir uns auf die eher
kleinere unterschiede was ja an sich
eine schöne sache ist also die die
tatsache dass es gleich wieder dass wir
jetzt keine heftigen schmerzen gegen
unseren willen leiden er sei dann eben
wir wollen aber ich meine diese
politische korrektheit ist ein
dauerthema bei hinein ist das eine gute
sache also gegen sprachliche
diskriminierung für für
gleichberechtigung in der sprache was
spricht dagegen ich benutze bewusst den
begriff nicht politische korrektheit wie
etwa auch gutmensch was für diese
kampfbegriffe sind und die völlig
zurecht dann wiederum deren gebrauch
kritisiert wird niemand und ich als
allerletzte hätte etwas gegen politische
korrektheit nur verstehe ich etwas
anderes stadt und genauso wie ein
gutmensch schlichter philanthrop wäre
das was fantastisch ist aber politische
korrektheit ist für mich nicht
zwangsläufig diversität der identitäten
sondern weniger diversität in
ökonomischen beispielsweise ich sehe
nicht ein warum man politisch korrekt
weniger ungleichheit genauer ökonomische
ungleichheit linkes augenlid ja was ein
bisschen verloren geht und ich finde mit
mit dem was auch verraten wird bewusst
wenn man von vielfalt spricht vielfalt
in der gesellschaft manche wollen
weniger vielfalt wollen eher klassisch
dazu gehören nicht sichtbar seien nicht
herausstechen sondern sich integrieren
auch aus ökonomischer art natürlich geht
es auch um anerkennung die ökonomie ist
nicht alles aber dennoch ist dass das
politisch korrekte
gleichzusetzen mit dem moralisch
korrekten bizarre diese meinung muss man
nicht vertreten dass politik und moral
nur weil uns das eine große moral
monopol die kirche weggebrochen ist dass
das jetzt plötzlich verschmelzen musste
zu einem bastard was erwiesenermaßen oft
schief gehen also dann ist die these
eigentlich der vorwurf an die linken
denen man ja oft hört schon bei
bridgewater mark lilla amerikanische
intellektuelle die gesagt haben die
linke hat sozusagen diesen diese
ungleichheit die klassenfrage ersten
blick verloren und hat sich jetzt ist
auch diese kulturellen identität
politischen merkmale fixiert wie
herkunft hautfarbe musste sie ja teil
wahr ist weil der alte klassenfeind der
sind sie also sie haben das kapital
teilweise in den händen ja also das sind
das sind selten arbeiter weil es die
arbeiterklasse und natürlich auch nicht
mehr gibt aber sie können wo müssen sie
jetzt ihre feinde suchen die rechte
macht das immer ganz klassisch von außen
man muss sich rein halten und abschirmen
aber links betreibt man jetzt eher
wieder diese ja diese diese statistische
paranoia nach innen und schauen wo wo
sind leute die sich links wählen aber es
eigentlich nicht sind ja man fühlt sich
dauernd unterwandert von meist eben
wirklich progressiven leuten künstlern
die die besten anlegen haben bei denen
man aber versucht die irgendwie denen
böse absicht nachzuweisen die wichtigere
eine lehre vertreten wir glauben einfach
innerhalb das lenkt die auch nicht so
menschenverachtend sind wie die
verfechter einer einer korrekten sprache
ich traue den menschen einfach zu dass
sie ohne geschriebene gesetze wissen wie
sie miteinander zu kommunizieren haben
aber offensichtlich ist das nicht so
weil wenn wir die mit den menschen reden
die sich diskriminiert fühlen oder die
sich nicht repräsentiert fühlen in der
sprache dann sagen sie nein das pärchen
änderung man kann ja beides machen das
eine tun das andere nicht lassen und
kann für ökonomische gleichheit
einstehen für wenige ausbeutung dieses
kleine ich halte es aber auch irgendwie
für regressiv jetzt man hat ja mehrere
pfeiler seiner identität es gibt
verschiedene und es ist wichtig dass es
mehrere gibt weil wenn mir einer
wegbricht stehe ich noch auf anderen
beinen jetzt in der ansprache rein auf
das geschlecht zu gehen was ich für
wahnsinnig veraltet halte ich bezahle
und da da enthüllt sich wieder dieser
regressive charakter mancher personen
die eine eine die konstruktive lehre
überflogen haben in der zusammenfassung
missverstanden um sehr gegen ihre
gründerväter anwenden aber wenn ich
natürlich als frau angegriffen dann muss
ich mich ja aus verteidigen ist ja nicht
so dass ich jetzt diese identität selbst
so wichtig finde sondern die
gesellschaft schreibt mir ja das auch zu
ihr und behandelt mich anders weil ich
eine andere hautfarbe habe und eine
andere herkunft des reichlich aber schon
das ist es ist so vielfältig waren sich
jemand durch frau angegriffen fühlt ich
fühle mich als frau angegriffen wenn ich
nicht wahrgenommen werde als frau
teilweise
also jetzt wirklich in verstehen sie man
sieht es auch bei meinen auftritten ich
möchte dass man mir die frau zu jedem
moment an sieht aber nicht anhört das
ist mir sehr wichtig dass mein denken
nicht weibisch gefärbt ist und deswegen
lege ich auch sehr viel wert darauf aber
auch nicht mehr ähnlich sondern was man
kritisch humoristisch ja und ich will
mir auch das spiel nicht nehmen lassen
schauen sie jetzt hier sitze ich als
künstler weil das geschlecht keine rolle
spielt mein unterkörper sieht man nicht
würden wir dann auch etwas trinken gehen
bin ich die künstlerin ja da habe ich
eine völlig andere körperhaltung das
heißt ich möchte auch in der ansprache
mir wie beim duzen und siezen ich möchte
mein geschlecht an und ausschalten
können und ich hatte den eindruck dass
war durch das ziel verflüssigte
identitäten aber leider muss es jetzt
doch alles festgeschrieben werden und
das verwirrt mich warum können wir nicht
mehr spielen warum kann es nicht am
vormittag so seien am nachmittag geladen
ist die gesellschaft noch nicht so weit
dass er ich habe jetzt noch bizarrer sie
sind es aber gerade die diese eigentlich
vorantreiben wollten die jetzt wieder
zurück wollen scheinbar war die freiheit
dann doch zu viel und das kann ich
verstehen freiheit ist in jeder form
eine zumutung die man aushalten muss und
die identität ist also auch eine
ersatzhandlung oder nicht der letzte
anker sozialen natürlich nach dem man
alles zerstört hat also dass das dass
ich sowieso vom thron gestoßen also die
ganzen stände sind verdampft vieles ist
weggebrochen und jetzt merkt man wo es
langsam sich auf eine freiheit zu bewegt
das ist einem nicht geheuer und man
krampft sich sehr verzweifelt an seine
identität an sein wahres selbst weil das
ist das letzte was man sich nicht zu
dekonstruieren getraut hat das wäre das
wirklich revolutionäre gewesen aber je
mehr man zerstört hat und euch
als patriarchale hetero normative
konstruktion entlarvt umso mehr schien
es wichtiger dass dieses innerste selbst
bleibt weil sonst hätte man nicht mehr
vor existieren könne aber gibt es das
nicht ist also wirklich nur eine
erzählung oder eine fiktion dieses
interessiert was sie machen
wahrscheinlich auch erfahrung wo sie
dinge tun dann spüren das passt nicht zu
mir das bin ich das gibt doch so was wie
das nicht fix aber ist das gibt es und
da wären wir wieder beim toilettengang
das ist das innere selbst ja wenn ich
müde krank oder sonst irgendwie
arrangiert bin dann bin ich selbst und
wir wissen das ist kein schöner anblick
also über dieses selbst diesen wirklich
grausigen kehren legen wir schichten von
kultur immer mehr wie bei seiner
mozartkugeln und je mehr schichten seien
umso schöner wird das eigentlich und
deswegen aber wir sind jetzt müssen wir
uns auch mit dieser inneren scheiße
anfreunden können sage ich jetzt mal was
die hörte dazu wir wissen ja dass das
hier zu hause wenn ich keine rolle
spielen so sind natürlich und ich finde
sie auf der bühne wahnsinnig lustvoll
deswegen wir jetzt auch schon gern fäkal
sowieso bei uns österreichern
wahrscheinlich weil wir die hochkultur
unserer monarchie haben das macht dann
spaß großen spaß in dem moment das
absoluten über menschen tun dann ihnen
wieder rein zu reiben was für
widerwärtige kreaturen sie im inneren
sind und auch ich bin natürlich ich
nehme mich da nicht aus und dieses
wechselspiel ist ein unfassbarer spaß
weil es ein wie auf der achterbahn den
marken aufhebt wenn man innerhalb von
sekunden eben vom über zum unter und
wieder zurück also das ist einfach etwas
schönes was ich nicht missen möchte
genau und aber viele finden sie gehen da
zu weit wir werden auch darüber reden
und auch noch lange nicht ansehen aber
vielleicht mal generell die frage beim
humor klar gibt es braucht vielleicht
sogar diesen tabubruch würden sie sagen
aber wie weit darf man gehen haben sie
für sich wie so eine leitlinie dingen
die sie nie machen würden nein ich finde
nämlich auch ich dränge man humor den
leuten nicht auf wenn leute zu mir
kommen dann zu kommen tun sie das
bewusst ich gehe nicht zu ihnen nach
hause und spielen dann im wohnzimmer
etwas vor sie entscheiden sich bewusst
und sie haben die domina schon
angesprochen ein bisschen so sehe ich
das also es ist es ist ein sado
masochistische sitzung so ein
kabarett-abend
und ich glaube niemand geht als freier
zu einer domina beschwert sich dann über
die aggression das wäre verfehlt die
leute wissen worauf sie sich einlassen
und die meisten kommen zu mir um sich
genussvoll peitschen zu lassen und das
sollte man denen nicht nehmen das sind
meist die kritiken kommen ja nicht von
innerhalb sondern von außerhalb wo
jemand etwas konsumiert von dem er weiß
dass es ihm nicht behagt seltsamerweise
sind diese leute was ja wohl bedacht
dass sie die richtigen lebensmittel
essen weil sie genau wissen worauf sie
allergisch sind und sie fehlen nicht zu
betonen dass sie das und das nicht essen
dürfen sie dürfen das um das nicht
schauen warum tun sie es dann nicht sie
wissen dass sie wegschauen ist und
sobald ich im fernsehen auftaucht die
menschen haben nicht nur das publikum
sondern auch sagen kritikerinnen
kritiker auch diskriminierte minderheit
es gab diesen riesen shitstorm große
debatte vor vor zwei jahren sie wurden
aus einem hamburger literaturfestival
wieder ausgeladen und der
antisemitismus beauftragte der deutschen
regierung felix klein meinte ihre
pointen basieren zitat auf
antisemitismus rassismus und
menschenfeindlichkeit ich glaube wir
schauen bevor wir darüber reden mal so
zwei passagen an die wir zusammen
geschnitten haben etwas verkürzt
geborener allen
königsberg
finden sie dieses mit honig sei
antisemitisch es ist ja wohl nur gut und
recht wenn wir den juden jetzt
gestarteten ein paar frauen aus
zugreifen
mit geld ist ja nichts gutzumachen
die erektion des schwarzen glied braucht
alles 7 liter blut über die ein mensch
verfügt
muss das sein
haben sie das nötig
ja ja in dem moment hatte ich es nötig
ist ich gehe nie auf die bühne und mache
irgendetwas spontan improvisiert das
bewahrt mich davor mich irgendwie zu
entschuldigen zu müssen weil ich denke
sehr wohl darüber nach es ist wo das
wort auswendig gelernt ja das wort für
wort niedergeschrieben und auswendig
gelernt das erleichtert mir die arbeit
nachher weil ich mich eben nicht mit
entschuldigung aber aufhalten muss und
das ist etwas derart
überzogene und im grunde nein ich bin
wirklich weiterhin der meinung man muss
es falsch verstehen wollen jeder wusste
zu dem zeitpunkt der sich damit
auseinandergesetzt hat was auch meine
haltung war zu mieten dass ich das
bizarre fand ohne jegliche verhandlung
dass der leute schuldig gesprochen
werden und es passiert eben nicht senden
was wir eher von den rechten kennen das
gerade wenn es um gewalt sexualisierte
gewalt gegen frauen geht das da gerne
ein bisschen rassismus mit schwingt und
das gerne im namen von von frauen sind
jetzt keine minderheiten wir haben es
nur geschafft sowie eine behandelt zu
werden dass man da dass man sich da
versteckt irgendwie dass man meint eine
gruppe retten zu müssen um andere eher
niederen triebe ausleben zu können und
im falle von me to waren es eben immer
diese drei namen und ich wollte ein
bisschen herumstochern dass jeder für
sich mal kurz rekapituliert aber nicht
aus anderen motiven auf diese männer hin
schlägt und mir war dieser dieser dieser
ausgebrochene männer hat mir war ja sehr
zuwider
und das wusste man insofern was umso
absurder dazu sagen das wäre die aussage
gewesen dass ich die jetzt nochmal
verurteilen möchte also das aber ich
meine fakt ist sie arbeiten mit
klischees mit stereotypen mit
abwertenden vorurteilen jetzt ist die
frage sie sind eine bühnenfigur das ist
glaube ich unbestritten das ist klar
aber werden diese vorurteile jetzt
entlarvt
unterlaufen oder werden sie
bekräftigt und bedient das ist ja die
frage oder perpetuiert man auch
bestimmte
stereotypen indem man sie vielleicht
ironisch verwendet aber es ist ja immer
der ausgangspunkt bei mir also so
handhabe ich es mit einer pointe
ausgangspunkt ist der stereotyp und der
wird dann gebrochen wie in diesem falle
also die die diese wo dieses motiv der
geldgier ist was dann gebrochen wird und
ich sagte nein nein es ist ganz anders
und sage ich wär ein anderes furchtbares
motiv und sollte doch ein
überraschungseffekt sein um aber
natürlich diese stereotype zu entlarven
also ich weiß nicht ich glaube wir sind
so weit dass ich natürlich weiß ich dass
es das gibt ja aber salonfähig ist weder
der rassismus noch der antisemitismus
und auf dieser basis
arbeite ich wenn es gängig wäre dass die
menschen sich offen rassistisch äußern
und auch meinen dazu zu stehen also um
sich wirklich für für für
völkerkunde halten die über über über
über verschiedene rassen diskutiert dann
würde ich das nicht machen sondern es
mache ich auf einer basis wo ich meine
es hat eine aufklärung dahingehend
stattgefunden und wenn wenn sich jetzt
jüdinnen und juden juden verletzt fühlen
diskriminiert fühlen
dann ist wäre ihre antwort sie haben das
falsch verstanden oder
es bewusst er falsch es wird sich immer
jemand gekränkt fühlen das kann man
nicht vermeiden der will es der
niemanden gekränkt der aber noch
irgendjemanden zum lachen bringt das
nicht erfunden
ich habe ein schönes zitat gelesen von
arno frank im spiegel und der schrieb
wer lacht bei bestimmten witzen bei
ihnen seien bereits in die falle
gegangen
fand ich interessant also die frage ob
man lachen sollen oder nachdenken so bei
bestimmten pointen bei lachen ist ja ich
meine sie haben auch sigmund freud
gelesen der witz und seine beziehung zu
unterbewussten ist man oft sind wie cr
sexistische rassistische mit diesen
vorteilen da kommt das wäre ein ventil
kommt irgendetwas das nicht sein darf
kommt zum ausdruck und es gibt
verschiedene arten warum das publikum
lacht ich will ihnen nicht die eine
verbieten und die die die andere
befördern was mir zum beispiel viel mehr
zuwider ist das lachen als ventil ist
das lachen um zu zeigen dass man einen
witz verstanden hat ist ja vor allem
wenn kulturelle referenzen agieren das
ist auch niedlich ja ich möchte das
nicht rügen aber es gibt unzählige
möglichkeiten des lachens und der
reaktionen und ich fordere keine
einzelne es gibt menschen die lachen
kann ein einziges mal in der schau
fühlen sich aber bestens unterhalten und
es gibt schon momente wenn die menschen
lachen dass ich sie darauf hinweise und
nochmal sie biete nachzudenken warum sie
jetzt gelacht haben war das angemessen
einfach nur das gebe ich ihnen mit als
ausübung für daheim also schon die
lehrerin auf der bühne pädagogen ein
nein ohne ohne einen gewissen ausgang es
gibt keine lösung für dieses ding ich
sage ihnen nur sie mögen nachdenken ich
habs jetzt wunderbar unterhalten sie
konnten sich selbst eigentlich
ausschalten aber sie sollen mal nicht
nur von ihrer von mir nicht sehr
geschätzten meinungsfreiheit gebrauch
machen sondern von ihrer
gedankenfreiheit zu der wir auch alle
aufgerufen sind das problem ist hat sich
also das wurde ihm nach vorgeworfen wenn
die forschen klagen was ist denn jetzt
irgendwie an diese story wird die afg in
deutschland glaube ich ihr foto auf
facebook verwendet hat
so also ist das nehmen sie einfach in
kauf und denke da kommt wieder der
monarchistische anspruch also wer die
weltherrschaft anstrebt für den gibt es
keine falschen ecke und ich denke wer
bei mir lacht der muss trotzdem
irgendwie da muss sich auch durch sehr
viel also die falschen jetzt
vermeintlich die müssen sich auch durch
sehr viel kritik an ihnen wühlen an so
einem abend da ist ihnen vielleicht eine
stelle vergönnt die sie falsch verstehen
wollen und schmutzig darüber lachen
dafür gibt es aber 20 die gegen sie
gehen und ich glaube nicht dass sich das
beherzte antisemiten antun bei mir in
die show zu gehen weil da springt für
sie nicht viel raus es gibt ja auch böse
stimmen vielleicht mal zum schluss die
sagen eigentlich sind sie wie wie so ein
kleines kind interessierte phase konnte
ihr kind wahrscheinlich noch bis 23
jahren ist es dann soweit meine kinder
sind schon da hat die sagen so zurück
wie sie gar kurzen so sagt man in der
schweiz also dinge die sie nicht sagen
dürfen unter der gürtellinie und freuen
sich unglaublich dieses tabu ist die
ganze zeit zu freitag ist da so ein
bisschen nein keineswegs also gerade es
ist lustig gerade von einer sehr
infantilen gesellschaft diesen vorwurf
zu hören die sich weigert nicht zu
sitzen und
natürlich sage ich was unter der
gürtellinie ist aber im österreichischen
haben wir diese hätten ehrliche
doppelbedeutung dass ein tiefer schnee
je nachdem was man sagen will er ist
erst tief weil es schmutzig unter der
gürtellinie es aber auch tiefgründig und
das tiefgründige und das abwegige das
ist das ist immer nah beieinander ich
kann nicht anders
vielleicht mit ihnen jetzt noch ein
bisschen über die rolle der von komik
und humor von satire auch für die
gesellschaft reden es gibt diesen
aufklären also aufklärungs philosophen
shaftesbury
der hat mal gesagt sport und satire ist
ein prüfstein für die wahrheit dass man
worüber man nicht lachen darf daher
daran sollte man auch nicht glauben so
wien testet man machen kann das muss die
was müssen unsere meinungen aushalten
sehen sie das auch so dass wir das als
demokratie als gesellschaft auch
brauchen ja wobei da da da sind eben
schon wieder zwei begriffe die ich dich
pfad auseinander halten möchte weil ich
ja sagt am main um die meinungsfreiheit
und die kunst beziehungsweise wenn wir
jetzt konkrete reden dieser tiere
freiheit wenn etwas meine kunst rahat
beeinträchtigt dann ist es die
meinungsfreiheit deswegen möchte ich
nicht dass menschen und das sind dann
meist das sind so instrumentale die
instrumentalisierung versuche wie von
der afg die meinen dannecker darf nicht
auftreten unsere meinungsfreiheit in
gefahr aneinander nein wenn ich nicht
auftreten darf dann ist es wegen einer
außer rand und band geratenen
meinungsfreiheit die ja keine freiheit
ist sondern ein meinungs- zwang er und
einer zur welt öffentlichkeit gekommenen
menschheit die sich jederzeit kundtun
kann und die kunstfreiheit das ist etwas
wo ich wirklich glaube das ist etwas
sehr wichtiges
und das muss ich kultivieren weil wir
schon gesagt freiheit ist anstrengend
und nicht jeder ist dafür gemacht ich
opfere mich quasi das klingt jetzt
wieder sehr sehr märtyrer haft aber es
ist so es passte dankeschön als als
künstler dass ich mich eine freiheit
annehme die für andere zu viel ist nicht
jeder sollte diese nach in freiheit
genießen zumal die leute das ich
genießen auch sehr viel verwehren also
das ist anstrengend ja und ich tue ihnen
eigentlich eingefahren in dem ich das
ausleben deswegen beschämt mich auch so
wenn ich jetzt können die nicht mehr
rauchen die nicht mehr trinken das ist
auch unsere aufgabe das nicht mein
persönliches pläsier sondern ich muss
etwas in sich verpflichtet zu rauchen
und zu trinken ja und dafür grenzen eine
31 zu leben ja für die von der ich
verstehe wenn menschen sagen war das ist
mir zu anstrengend ich möchte lieber so
reden wie es mir vorgeschrieben wird und
das tun was mir vorgesetzt wird das ist
das ist verständlich
und ich nehme mich aber dieser freiheit
an und lädt sie ein bisschen für uns
alle aus kunstfreiheit ist absolut da
gibt es auch rechtliche grenzen es gibt
rechtliche grenzen ja die die werden
dann die sind ja wirklich
festgeschrieben und das ist auch das ist
auch in ordnung aber ja kunst darf alles
ich finde von der richtung zukommen
einfacher als zu sagen sie darf nichts
und dann einzeln zu erläutern was sie
dann doch darf auch hier würde ich sagen
es
wäre leichter wenn wir wieder
zurückfinden würden kunst ästhetisch zu
beurteilen das haben wir uns verboten
weil wir haben in diesen bereichen
kreativ kommunismus dass jeder ein
künstler schon alles ist kunst ist
natürlich quatsch
aber nachdem wir gesagt haben gemischen
der show behandeln wir wollen weiter
kunst kritisieren
und jetzt haben wir denn hinter weg über
die moral genommen das kunstwerk ist
immer großartig was jemand hin schmiede
das ist wahnsinn aber der künstler der
als moralisch verwerflich dass unsere
letzte möglichkeit sein um noch bewerten
zu können also ist sie sagen es findet
eine moralisierung stadt auch im
kunstbetrieb damit wir überhaupt noch
sagen können ob etwas besser oder
schlechter ist weil das können wir nicht
verbannen weil wir uns das eingehandelt
haben dass es schönheit letztlich nicht
gibt weil alles schön ist diese
demokratisierung der ästhetik was
furchtbar finde wo wir alle nur
verlieren können dass jetzt jeder und
alles schön ist ist es dann überhaupt so
gerhard richter und so weiter das gibt
der rankings und es gibt es bestimmte
künstlerinnen die erweist roben sind
punkt ja ja also nicht originär sind
natürlich ja also es gibt na ja das wird
dann auf grausame art wird es natürlich
natürlich haben wir eine unter dieser
vermeintlichen demokratisierung gibt es
eine grausamkeit des markt dass die man
nicht leugnen kann also es wird bitter
böse aus sortiert ja und da sind gute
leute darunter das macht das ganze ja
umso zynischer diese diese ja die
demokratisierung von einem guten und
wahren und schönen oder
repariert er aus und unterstützt und das
dass das wenig in vielerlei hinsicht
schade ja dass schönheit jetzt ins auge
des betrachters gelegt wurde das
bedeutet nämlich letztlich es gibt keine
schönheit in der welt wieder ich
erschaffe sie mit meinem blick und das
macht die welt zu einem tristen ort und
es nimmt uns auch die fähigkeit ich
finde es schöner wenn demokratisiert ist
dass jeder das gute und schöne sehen
kann als dass es allem innewohnt und so
sehe ich auch ein bisschen das was ich
mache mir ist es wichtig dass es für
alle ist ich möchte nichts elitäres
machen oben bin elitär ich stelle mich
über das gesamte volk in seiner einheit
wo ich nicht trennen dass es wahnsinnig
demokratisch in seiner womöglich ltm
geste sie sollen sich untereinander
solidarisieren mit
meinetwegen gegen mich aber da würde ich
keine unterschiede machen sie würden
also das schöne vom guten auch radikal
trennen sozusagen kunst autonomie oder
gibt es nicht auch eine verbindung ist
machen wir nicht auch das schöne
irgendwie ein schöner anblick oder ein
schönes design spiegelt sich darin nicht
auch ein lebens ideal von von eleganz
von leichtigkeit und so etwas schon also
dass das sage ich auch den leuten
bewusst dass ich ästhetik für die beste
ethik halte also schönheit wird die welt
retten also war ursprünglich bei
dostojewski kann man das auch so das was
bringt aus drin
weil ich meine dass man sich dass man
sich da steckt uns schon ein bisschen
intuition in gegen das gegen das
hässliche sträubt ja dem auch immer
etwas und nicht indem sie eine
lasterhafte wie ich es verfechter
sondern wirklich etwas etwas einfach ein
schönes inne wohnt ja und dass man dass
man sich dagegen sträubt gegen krieg und
und ging gegen jede form von leiden ich
bin auch sehr gegen eine ästhetisierung
von leiden sondern immer für eine
sublimieren nicht einfach das leid
abzusondern und das als kunst zu
begreifen
nein es mag ein motor sein aber der
motor ein pferd nicht ja also ich muss
schon noch eine schöne karosserie darum
bauen und dann ist dieser womöglich
dieses initiale leiden zündet die ganze
geschichte aber dabei bleiben darf es
nicht das fände ich das finde ich auch
als empfinde ich als home wenn man das
leiden stilisiert das sollte nicht sein
da sind wir wieder ein bisschen bei
sigmund freud und die sublimation
daher endlich eine echte frage also ich
find humor ist eine form von lebenskunst
mit schwierigen situationen umzugehen
aber es steckt auch die gefahr darin
dass man über dinge hinweg lacht also
bei freud gibt es die sache manchmal
erspart man sich eine hemmung sun fand
man muss irgendwie die sachen nicht mehr
unterdrücken aber manchmal spart man
sich auch gefühle im mitleid wie ärger
und so weiter man lacht einfach über die
dinge hinweg und da steckt ja auch eine
gefahr drohe gefahr von flucht also ich
kenne einige menschen mit den ich sagen
würde die haben nicht den mut bestimmte
dinge ernst zu nehmen ja wichtig zu
nehmen sich selbst einmal wichtig zu
nehmen
ja dass ich glaube nicht dass es zu
einer abstumpfung kommt ich glaube
nämlich solange sie lachen gab es eben
immer schon diese ersten diesen effekt
des mitleids der trauer die sie dazu
bewegt darüber hinweg zu lachen ich
würde immer denken wenn dieser effekt
nicht mehr 30 dann gefolgt auch nicht
das lachen und ich glaube nicht dass der
effekt
abstumpft das würde ich würde ich nicht
meinen ich glaube nicht dass man das man
zu viel lachen kann beziehungsweise
denke ich dass ich solche dinge rechen
natürlich wenn dann pusteln sie
irgendwie auf das wissen wir ja in form
von kleiner neurosen und sixx aber
solange die nicht mit einem extremen
leidensdruck verbunden sind können sie
ja auch wiederum dann nicht für ein
selbst aber zumindest für die umwelt
erheiternd wirken und schon wieder lacht
jemand anderes und das lachen nicht
verloren gegangen es gibt von dem
philosophen helmuth plessner übrigens
schon gesprochen haben dieser grenze
reaktion weinen und lachen gibt es
schöne zitat aus komik sei ein triumph
des seins über die eindeutigkeit
also man spricht heute von ambiguität
toleranz also ist es für sie eine
wichtige dimension von humor dass man
mit widersprüchen leben kann in
konkurrenzen dinge die einfach irgendwie
zusammen da sind wie das klo und
auf jeden fall bei dieser ambiguität
toleranz bin ich mir einfach nicht
sicher weil die wird menschen oft
unterstellt auch um natürlich seine
eigenen witze zu rechtfertigen ich finde
dass die menschen aber eher in einer
während am beach sind und
widersprüchlich teilweise das heißt ich
finde diese diagnose irgendwie falsch
also menschen die mich kritisieren da
bin ich am bioethischen tolerant weil
ich nicht verstehe wie sehr sie hin und
her hobson zwischen dekonstruktion und
essential ismus wissen sie am vormittag
demonstrieren sie für den klimawandel
und sein volk der wissenschaft am
nachmittag ist jeglicher form von
biologie eine konstruktion das ist am
big das muss man erst mal aushalten und
manchmal komme ich da nicht mit deswegen
würde ich nicht sagen das würde ich
nicht das ist ein begriff den man immer
wieder hin schleudert wenn man sein sich
verteidigen zu müssen ich mache es mir
nicht leicht ich nehme nicht die
schlagworte und sagt ihr seid das und
dass die qualitäts intoleranz finde ich
ist erstmal was normales wenn man auf
einen offensichtlichen widerspruch stehe
ja so will ich niemandem verwehren mann
verbrachte konsequenz also dieses
beispiel dass sie gesagt haben ist
einfach das eklatante widerspruch und
den sollte man nach auflösenden leben
weil die dinge passen nicht ja also da
darf man dann auch darüber reden ja und
ich wehre mich auch gegen diesen was
dann auch immer so locker hingeworfen
wird man muss doch kritik aushalten
können und das wenig grundsätzlich auch
ja wir sollten nur definieren wird
kritik ist irgendwo geht es auch da
unter die gürtellinie also nicht alles
ist kritik aber das alles kritik und
diskutierbar und würdig es das finde ich
auf jeden fall also nur nicht das
gespräch abzubrechen
also ich nehme im laufe eines gesprächs
gern dann die gegenteilige position 1
nur um das gespräch ja nicht zum
erliegen zu bringen weil ich einfach nur
an dem rhetorischen gefecht gefallen
finden sie es heute nicht gemacht
nein ich glaube diese
seien bislang nicht das ist schade ja
weil ich nehme den benjamin sehr sehr zu
herzen also immer radikal niemals
konsequent aber eine kehrtwendung stimmt
bin ich ihnen noch schuldig
nicht mehr viel zeit aber neues buch das
kommt von jedem boom ende august an 22
erscheint dass
das ist auch vieles und nicht nur eines
da steht drauf hinten als ein märchen
eine horrorgeschichte ein erotik krimi
ein comic ein computerspiel satire was
denn
es vielleicht kann ich damit manchen
schmackhaft machen die mich sonst nicht
mitlesen würden es geht irgendwie in
gewisser hinsicht geht es um
identitätspolitik es geht um
minderheiten es geht vorrangig um in dem
buch jetzt hohen [ __ ] models das
scheint erst nicht zusammenzupassen aber
es geht um körper in einer zeit die sich
sehr buddy positiv will möchte ich
eigentlich die körperfeindlichkeit das
ganzen denunzieren und das sind eben
figuren die wirklich von ihren körpern
leben ich kokettiere immer mit einem
dualismus dass nur der geist zählt und
der körper ist eine widerwärtige höhle
jetzt wo ich aber sehe wie körper
feindlich meine zeit genauso sind auf
eine sehr erschreckende weise revidiere
ich das eigentlich sollen sie diese
körper durch digitalisierung
der beständige wunsch sich loszuwerden
und eigentlich jetzt in ein bizarres
säkularisierte form natürlich in die
cloud abzulegen wenn ich das so sagen
darf und
dahinter man merkt auch hinter buddy
positive das bräuchte man nicht wenn man
nicht zutiefst verfeindet wäre mit den
körpern und nichts ist uns leicht genug
ja das ist auch ein natürlich in der
umweltschutzbewegung sofort in vielen
das positive zieht muss ich vielleicht
auch sagen dass sagt dass eine
gegenbewegung zu dieser
selbstoptimierung des körpers sagt jeder
körper ist okay so ria sich zu lieben ja
aber natürlich da gibt es dann strömen
wo auch wieder was extrem
widersprüchlich ist eigentlich sind wir
zu schwer immer wieder wir sind zu
schwer für die welt wir sollen die welt
gefälligst so hinterlassen wie wir sie
vorgefunden haben und da sind wir wieder
bei der toilette das lese ich auf
toiletten und ich möchte die welt nicht
wie einen lokus behandeln ich möchte
mich ihr aufdrücken das ist auch unser
ziel aber gerade dass dieser druck
dieser aufdruck der fußabdruck etwas zu
hinterlassen und das ist kultur das
wurde zu einem schandmal erklärt unser
ökologischer fußabdruck dabei wozu sind
wir hier wenn nicht diese welt zu prägen
aber nicht mit einem zu großen
ökologischen fußabdruck oder wollen sie
dass der fußabdruck dass das genommen
wurde als sinnbild dass wir möglichst
leicht wieder gehen sollten dass das
finde ich schade diese verkehrung dass
wir nicht mehr den ahnen etwas schuldig
sind sondern nur mehr unseren enkeln
also und kann doch beides gefälligst in
betracht ziehen das ist aber dass es
dann nur dieses extrem gibt dass diana
nichts mehr wert sind das sind völlig
auch wieder alte toren die alles falsch
gemacht haben und die jugend die noch
gar nicht geboren ist die ist von einer
also dieser die überhaupt die jugend
dieser dieser dieser kleine hausgott den
wir jetzt haben die wüste ist die wäre
nicht kulturell versaut und
da kommen wir wieder in die untiefen von
russo wo ich jetzt nicht da wollen weil
ich ja wir sind hier am ende der zeit
zum schluss
würde ich ihnen gerne vor laufender
kamera ist das du anbieten nicht wie sie
reagieren ich dachte sie wollten wir an
die brüste fassen
es ist das glaubt das nicht so einladend
wir waren nicht zuvor sie beginnen und
aufhören dazu sage ich nichts
herzlichen dank wir nehmen das du an
nein das halte ich mich überwinden sich
jetzt aber sie haben wahrscheinlich
diesen großen tisch bekommt und nächsten
lassen dass wir lassen es bleiben sie
dürfen nicht jetzt jetzt können wir nach
der sendung sagen
vielen dank ihnen fürs fürs mitdenken
nächste woche tauchen wir ein in die
welt von instagram tik tok und youtube
in die welt der sozialen medien aus und
fragen was macht das ständige sehen und
gesehen werden mit uns und wir wollen
wir als gesellschaft damit umgehen und
jetzt gleich reisen wie in die teuerste
stadt welt und das ist nicht etwa paris
hongkong oder zürich sondern tel aviv
ein film über den stadtteil jaffa und
über seine widersprüche glanz aus daran
und bis bald
[Musik]